depuis près d'un mois il ya un sursaut
une prise de conscience quasi mondiale
sur la question du racisme de québec
nous pas épargné ici aussi on dénonce un
racisme systémique
on a tendance à confondre les choses
lorsqu'on parle de racisme systémique on
va penser que c'est un racisme
systématique preuve que tout le monde
est raciste
personne ne concerne telle chose ou
alors on va penser en fait que seulement
des individus sont 1,6 alors que le vrai
problème ce n'est pas les volontés
individuelles entente est le vrai
problème c'est les structures et les
mécanismes politiques juridiques socio
économique qui bloque en fait donc
l'ensemble des efforts pour changer
véritablement les choses
l'auteur est professeur dv d'austin a
beaucoup écrit sur la question raciale
il ya cinq ans il signe le livre [ __ ]
noir [ __ ] blanc où ils rappellent
l'histoire des relations raciales au
québec des interactions haïtiens qui est
venu dans les années 60 est allé cinq
ans soissons qui a beaucoup influencé le
conversation sur la nationalisme cela
anticolonialisme la révolution du point
qui s'était pas seulement le mouvement
des francophones il ya des gens des
antilles dès qu'arrivent des jeannois
qui a participé dans ce mouvement
on peut dit qu' ils ont pas ils ont pas
profité dans le même sens
durant la révolution tranquille au
québec plusieurs comme pauline julien
gaston miron s'inspirait des auteurs
comme aimé césaire frantz fanny et de
tous les mouvements de libération pour
le peuple québécois
beaucoup de francophones comme pierre
vallières s'identifier aux minorités
noire aux etats-unis selon des vélos
steen il y avait une ouverture un
dialogue mais la minorité noire au
québec a été oublié ils sont une
minorité dans la contexte canada
cette attitude comme minorité d'après
massivement la réalité des vrais
minorité dans le contexte urbain et si
on se fie aux statistiques la réalité
des minorités n'est pas toujours
reluisantes les communautés noah par
exemple vont être se représenter au
niveau des arrestations policières ou
vont être ceux représentés par exemple
lorsqu'il s'agit de regarder l'état de
la santé publique
ce n'est pas étonnant par exemple que
des quartiers comme montréal nord a été
plus ciblés par la pandémie
selon christian nadeau il faut aller au
delà des manifestations
si on veut vraiment changer les choses
alors se posent les politiques de gauche
quand l évolution tranquille du premier
ministre
pour moi le mot évolution c'est
tellement difficile parce que évolution
c'est comme un synonyme de passion s'il
faut qu'on soit à sion c'est comme les
choses ont changé le monde et si un vrai
dialogue reprenait pour éradiquer une
fois pour toutes le racisme ici à des
bootleggers glisse radio-canada en rien